I'm here to do the moderating one out
for the panel I have nothing to do this
bond show of them I adore I was talking
to both Seth and Evan earlier to that on
repeats of the same information I said
which was you guys are doing the [ __ ]
Lord's work here man like I remember
behind the first issue of preacher off
the stand and you know as I was is still
somewhat the lapsed Catholic England I
fell in love with the book instantly by
the middle of the run I was like this
has to happen somebody has to make this
man and I fell in love with the writer
the person who put this beautiful piece
of work into the world let's bring him
out here as well give it up for the
amazing guard so like everybody who's
ever picked up read you read the comics
read the trade paperback everyone's
always said the same thing this has to
be a movie this has to be a TV show
somebody has to bring this into the real
world
so from a young age I was like man this
would be a great thing to see it was
undoable four years of years I was
involved at one point with people that
tried to do it as well Rachel Talalay
the director still directs today and did
episode of the flash last season at one
point she tried to bring it to life and
I meant Garth in the world of comics and
yet expressed for the plan I was so you
know he was like we're trying to put
this preacher movie together would you
think about being Broussard I was like
let me tell you something that helps at
all to throw my name around make me a
[ __ ] producer man and they use money
and nothing [ __ ] had so
the other better filmmakers that may
also took a shot and like Sam Mendes
tried to do it also didn't pull together
a montage but it took two kids from
Canada of all places who fell in love
with this material long before they were
tread the boards and telling their
stories on a wide scale to kids exactly
like pretty much everyone in this
audience who read a comic book and fell
in love with it man and some people took
a swipe at trying to make it happen I
tried to help once and once they were
like your names uses those like I'm out
of this my name is balls between you all
these cats kept up the dream man and
they both enjoyed wonderful success
building than making writing directing
and being in the movies that they want
to make it stuff hysterical rocking
things that have nothing to do with the
world of creature yet never lost that
dream and got to a power point at some
point where they even pissed off [ __ ]
Korea SAS finally they were just like
forget it man let's let's go for broke
and let's go fishing and they literally
did the impossible
they brought preacher to life that
deserves a massive
okay so everyone whoever's in the Saudi
is unfamiliar with the show how come
you're not watching right now go watch
preaching to watch episodes on amc.com
big DVD blu-ray is coming out October
4th and find that of Amazon there's
still two more episodes left you just
saw the end of one of them you watch the
game perform an ultimate episode I got
one more episode left which we can all
enjoy next week and then see someone's
done you guys got picked up correct
we didn't yet well but this may be
exciting so I was wondering like this is
going to happen all season and yes it is
happening that's Natalie on July 31st is
due to be followed by talking preacher
man with special guest Seth Rogen Evan
Goldberg and a bloody man that's [ __ ]
fantastic
I know it's great we got one of those
talking chose not to do the whole thing
to get your voice yeah technically yes
let's let's get a role in it and then
I'm only going to ask you questions I
want to open up to you you guys the fans
have I want to know a lot of things when
US will open up to you guys best
possible but to get it gone you're huge
fans the comics what was what we most
nervous about bringing to the screen
I'll be honest with you or not who's
doing that integer sorry I saw this
behavioral issue from video ask our
[ __ ] outfit man you've got to
misbehave I have the idea and it just
starts happening sorry
it's good that's good I hope nobody does
it this
Coke's bun no you fine else's uh I
watched the first episode when I sat
down watching until you guys - earlier
today I sat down and launched it looking
for issue by it she was like okay
they're going to do issue by issue every
episode will be like an issue of
preacher and what I got instead was a
remix like it reminded me of what they
do at the model moves I went to see
Civil War
it wasn't the Civil War I knew from the
gommage but was close enough so they got
in there fix developments you felt like
you guys took the box that preacher
crayons dumped it out and then just
repositioned them and then presented it
back and painted a new canvas how did
you ride on that reserved a moment where
you were like we got it to the books
just the books um it's my turn for huge
[ __ ] we asked them to separate us for
this exaggeration things aren't going
well the problem is being a became each
other now we're joke initially we when
we pitched it to ABC we very
specifically pitched exactly what you
just said you expected and they loved
that idea
and then sat with Garth and he explained
to us why we shouldn't do that and why
there was a lot of nice ways to enhance
it as long as we maintain the spirit of
it and keep it kind of core values yes
he agrees I think he said I mean Odyssey
one of the early revelations from Garth
is that it just wouldn't timeout like if
we did do a literal adaptation of it it
probably just wouldn't give us enough
for you know the 15 seasons we want to
do a preacher and so it was a nice
please 100 bonding over bungalow exact
but and so good once you guys you have
to kind of change anything then you
realize like oh all of it other than
like this the tone the characters the
main kind of overarching stories we
should inflexible with at least talk
about changing in again just with the
goal of making like the best TV show who
could make whether you'd read the comic
or not really and I think the most
nerve-racking changes that tulips
character is a little different and that
was like a core character and changing
Jesse's father was also big changed that
we did not take lightly and you know and
they were all part of like we wanted to
just make it one story more we wanted to
make we wanted to give tulip and Jesse
more of a shared history we wanted to
make the reason Jesse we want to make
his relationship with God much more
personal than it was in the comic to
some degree of never see him being a
preacher in the comic it just kinda just
never really emotionally invested in it
and so all that was stuff we talked
about that maybe we could you know add
to that and Garth you instigated all the
changes you weren't like like no man do
my book you were like now [ __ ] with my
book no I was I realized fairly early on
we're gonna have to mess with it I was
okay with that that the colleague has
this breathless piece to it that would
be impossible to capture on screen it
would be weird for a TV audience and you
would burn yourself of material in God a
season and a half it'd be great season
and a half so the I said I maintained
that all I did was confirmed the
suspicion that said that Evan had
already come to which was you're gonna
have to change it but keep the spirit
giving example in the very first issue
of the book to up happens to run into
Cassidy when she needs a ride out of a
gunfight and later that very first
episode they happened the plastic little
Texas on where her ex-boyfriend happens
to be the preacher
there's several coincidences at once
rapid-fire well in the show it all makes
sense of course she goes back there
because she's from there and of course
joseline's there jumped out of a plane
in it's full of stuff I wish I'd thought
of highest probably given we got a
definite it's great what has been your
favorite moment to see come to life of
the stuff that you know you had your
hand painting watching come to life the
shield killing every single thing you
see yeah cool we got to just witness
that first yeah stunning just insanely
well shot so cinematic it's crazy was
that the idea of going in like let's
make it look like one long movie yeah we
actually wanted to make it look like
several different movies honestly we you
know the comic has so many one little
tangents inside stories and when new
characters are
it really kind of takes you to these new
worlds and we wanted visually to do that
same thing to give the different
characters you know until they enter
like our main story their own aesthetic
their own look their own fields and then
to kind of collide them the general look
of the show but that was something that
we talked a lot about that we just
haven't seen a lot of on television or
shows that were visually unpredictable
where you really didn't know what it was
going to look like what you might be
watching the first five minutes of it
anything for watching the wrong show
which was oddly something we strive for
was to really make it on a stylistic
level you didn't know what to expect
just as much as on a story mode no it's
Dominic let's talk about trail playing
one of the most complex characters on
television when you first get it again
to it already it resisted in all because
as far as I'm concerned you're
absolutely [ __ ] crushing thank you
very much yeah I was very I was scared
because I knew and I understand the fan
base and what as you were saying earlier
and now becoming you know becoming so
well now understand what they meant to
the people who read them and grow up
with them and I know hear people talk
about them and that character with such
passions yeah but a big part of people's
life it's something you're taking on a
roll and I was not hesitant in any way i
was desperate to do play the part
whether i thought i could do and i was
never sure thing i was helped so much
along the way it's been an incredible
journey of learning discovery and who
this guy is and you I become as most of
us have done more we've got
specifics of the care and a care but for
the fans that have a specific mind sense
about who they are it's been you habits
wealth of information this beautifully
illustrated comic book and you can
always refer back to it and get a lot of
them ideas from that but it was
wonderful that we had that the idea was
there that when we go back and discover
who they were from the beginning from
before the comic start and yes a
constant that learning everything over
time by it's been exciting to watch to
be watching over these last few weeks is
is much more dislikeable and I thought
it was he's really awful yeah it comes
out look at this one yeah I thought it's
been very nice yes and I need to be kind
clear why this particular person can
maintain this entity what it is about
him and that says a lot
this is my in mind interpretations that
he's capable of that because he is
Harvey of good coffee he's able to
answer and keep them sort of exploding
within him that says a lot about him Lee
knowing about his past and that
relationship with the father the work
these guys have done to created a
backstory yeah it's been it has been
tough basically to find a feeling pretty
one and to trust in hope that people
take to my interpretation
I was saying to you earlier today to
your man that walks between two worlds
and your other job sometimes you're
Howard Stark and then also here you're
you've got one foot harm on one foot in
the DC Universe by doing preacher which
would you if you had to pick doesn't
make her head down anything you say it
in front of your boss they probably made
a lot better yep roof ah - hands down
strongest female character on television
right now he flexes hell but strong to
sell strong role model level of the toys
like a strong female role models of
comics good lord
tulip as a man when you see the script
are you thrilled is there any hesitation
about material you're like oh this is
mine when I saw their original script
yeah um I mean there was no hesitation I
mean I was sort of from a kind of
lobbied the [ __ ] I just I find her
say I've heard you say thrilling I find
everything about her so it's Joy's
player
because I just I very much enjoy seeing
woman you can be quite dark I'm new
what's also quite funny there's a lot of
humor dinner and I like the way I like
the way she's she sort of Bates and sort
of people who she should like bigger
guys I'm saying every guy loves a girl
who Bates
I just I feel like a there's not many
people like discovery for most people
haven't seen character that strong and
it's just it's just a lot of fun and the
guys that chemistry that you guys share
is pretty wonderful had you first these
two they were definitely going yeah how
long did you get to work with one of
their before you dive into episode one
these two we rehearse oh just ant just
talk about on the first little finger
penis we reversed a little yeah I got
Restless that was it I didn't say
critics rivers will he believe that
winning another way that wasn't possible
more than usual we got a walker on her
side we don't know the time I got
another three it was like I mean we had
three directors essentially first two
because we had sand that yeah all had
incredible influence yeah and it was so
specific and didn't ripples and this and
we had time to go over over and over the
scenes make sure that they were in the
right place
when she ready bet it was we had a week
yeah I think personal don't we like
every day and it was really it was
amazing any of it was it was so fun you
guys great you're you you know you do
have a good dynamic which makes you very
hard to control but but it comes across
wonderful we discovered it all in the
rehearsal the greedy Jenna think me very
very cool did you do like an ad libbing
pan thing like Jerry rehearsals were
people allowed to add two inspectors you
stick to the script
we mostly stuck to the script I mean Joe
deep it's not like Joe has added things
here there yeah it's all dusty you know
Sam Sam our showrunner is not as he
doesn't come from the same compromise a
tional background I guess I guess I'm
breaking that they didn't rip as much
because we do is probably for good
reason so yeah it's shirtless improv
than anything we've ever done which is
why I think it looks better than
anything we've ever done because when
you're not improvising you could
actually film think you regular movies
and you've got just cross covering
everything and so I think the lack of
improv I think in times is what's what
happens to the show so much Joe I met
you yesterday we were chit chat and tell
them how you got into acting in the
first place I got into some [ __ ] with
the place and I was like a five I was in
it I when I was young I couldn't I
couldn't ready to ride I'm still not
great at it and so I used to a couple
hours my behavior was not good and so
ended up being said he was like I was
being sent through acting school as
punishment off me dad's like you want
I want to be a [ __ ] clown you go in
here I'm just reading the back of this
please be aware many members of the
audience there'd be under the age of 18
champion watching creature you are here
you're gonna upset about swear words
your own [ __ ] fault so what was that
what the [ __ ] was so yes I got in
trouble so I had to go and do that
anyway ended up getting a job I got
sectioned off and by this guy called
Davy Jones and shout-out to him and now
he said these kids we can start doing
something with and we have known we have
a lot of money at the time we're your
family and so they paid for me to go on
the books and end up getting a job
straight away because I didn't realize I
was young you know I didn't realize
realize how big a deal it was
that's more than television and that
went on for three years and then I got
with a left back show and I went through
spots you know in a bit like John
Merrick for a while and just
unemployable nightmare
got into girls going to drugs which is
[ __ ] ace man
that really slows them down considerably
and it's left me with drug-induced
bipolar so that's where I got cheer that
come on that's a that's a terrible role
model Eddie yeah drug-induced bipolar
2016 [ __ ] yeah so I'm compacting
completely biopsy I'm so lucky I'm not
in jail man
my friends in and you know our family
very proud Thank You Leon this is a big
deal nice about you honestly like jock
decide this job is hockey I've never
seen this many people
brand we just watched the end of the
episode of pretty much how to confirmed
we just had it confirmed for us that you
definitely you're not the saint of
killers I don't know who hit it when you
got the script were you familiar with
the book and did you know oh my god I'm
gonna play the same killer oh yeah I was
very familiar with word so I was a huge
fan of things I've read them when they
first came out I had reread them and
when I learned just heard that they were
doing this I was obviously desperate to
be involved and but one of the things
that when you love something that much
and I do and love these books reading
them it's nobody you know you and you
feel that responsibility and you want to
honor the source material and so when I
put that coat on a hat when you know the
armor came and gave me those guns you
think it feels a really big thing and I
don't say that lightly I am I'd be lucky
enough to do some really fun things in
my life and this really did take the
cake so I'm very proud very happy to be
involved it's
so your on-screen demeanor is like 180
degrees from your off-screen I get it
all out that's that that way it can be
nicer in you've got the most enviable
job on television man that if I was that
was the role that I would definitely
want to go for it's one of the most
memorable characters from the book maybe
right after preacher himself when you
see the role did you know the book first
no no I wasn't super familiar with the
comics I had gotten an email so there's
a character called our space about this
and I googled it and I was like okay uh
but then I read about it and I kind of
got from human with preacher I realized
what a huge bomb and man I was just so
desperate to be able to get to play the
part
so I I'd send the tape
how do you send in tape on being a
healin [ __ ]
yeah um no it was specially recorded and
I send it to my agent for like you guys
don't want to send this I understand
like I'm drooling all over myself and
spitting everywhere is particularly good
at tells you use your [ __ ] patience
okay now before all these cats kids
attacked they probably sit there think
about their barbers of like that before
you get to act you gotta sit - how long
is the makeup process and you yeah it
takes about two two and a half
and you can't keep yeah I can't eat what
I'm wearing it it covers like my whole
face on my nose so if you sneeze well
it's pretty disgusting and are you just
like sick of smoothies forever now I am
yeah I say it's like doing smoothies on
off-screen our states like the most
impressive example of method acting but
yeah you know it's amazing the guys
designed it my god watching like last
week's episode makeup looks incredible
it's really cool I was just [ __ ]
delighted that like they didn't wait you
bury the lead yep another vanya like our
space those are good my favorite camera
funny I asked I live it was found this
on my phone and I look for it so I
thought I had it it's an email that I
wrote in 2008 to sanben niece who at
this time was the director of preacher
it says I'd never met him I can't email
address it says how are you
I mean I'd like to tell you I would do
anything to be considered for the role
of our space in your preacher movies
I've never said one of these emails I
instantly regretted but what's done is
done
Oh Paul as well and my favorite comic of
all time just found its way and I'm glad
my favorite comic of all time has found
its way into the hands of such a
talented filmmaker thanks dude uh he
emailed back to say I can't find me no
he did he did he go back to say hey if I
get it coming
if you have an opportunity to audition
and that never happened but that is how
long you're trying to do this and it
shows that our space is always been my
favorite character because I wanted to
play 1 2 million years ago
you